hi everyone
hope you're safe and doing well thank
you for joining this session
on google cloud's ai adoption framework
ai is increasingly the new frontier in
digital transformation
and is well positioned to drive value
across all aspects of an organization
we believe that the enterprises that
invest in building custom ai
and industry solutions are better
positioned to be the global economic
leaders of tomorrow
as mckinsey's paper modeling the impact
of ai on the world economy
indicated companies that fully absorb ai
could double their cash flow we will be
presenting on a framework aimed at
enabling organizations to build an
effective ai capability
informed by google's own evolution in ai
as well as many years of experience in
helping cloud customers
solve complex challenges from startups
to enterprises
in various industries so if you're
looking to help your organization
leverage ai successfully whether at the
start
or far along your journey you're in the
right session
as you may have seen we recently
published a white paper on this
which khalid and i wrote with the help
of many experts from across google
our co-authors barbara finn valentin
lac and us are available to answer your
questions
during this week to briefly introduce
ourselves
i'm donna a technical account manager
defining strategic roadmaps with our
advanced machine learning customers
and overseeing the delivery of
large-scale
cutting-edge projects and i'm khalid a
cloud solutions architect
focusing on designing and building
machine learning systems on google cloud
before going into the framework itself i
wanted to share
why i'm so passionate about this i used
to play chess
at an international level and this
sparked my interest in ai
it showed me how ai can push the
boundaries of our thinking
and accelerate our learning a good
example of this
is alpha zero a machine learning system
developed by deep mind that plays
chess this gave a new perspective on how
to effectively play the game
and in a similar way ai can give us a
new perspective on how to solve business
challenges
more than ever i think it's important
that we leverage ai
to tackle the big societal problems like
health and sustainability
while the value of ai is clear building
an a
capability presents challenges customers
often seek our advice
on how they can leverage machine
learning effectively to gain business
value
they ask us questions like what role
should we hire and how should we
structure our teams
as you move from creating models to
putting them into production
different skill sets are required and
how can we make data discoverable
shareable and reusable
one of the key blockers of ai adoption
is the lack of high quality data and
making it accessible in a secure way
on top of that they ask us how can we
deploy and operate machine learning
models
in production at scale customers aspire
to run powerful algorithms on large data
sets
while controlling costs building an ai
capability
encompasses many different aspects and
focusing on just one aspect
like the technology and not the people
needed to implement it
can result in wasted resources and no
impact
that's why it's so important to have a
clear roadmap
working with customers we wanted to help
them be successful
no matter where they are in their
journey so a year ago
we envisioned a framework to enable
organizations to leverage
machine learning effectively and gain
business value
chess is about creating a vision and
defining the steps to get there
we applied the same structure to
building ai capabilities and conceived
the ai
adoption framework
google cloud's ai adoption framework is
essentially a guide for organizations
who want to build an effective ai
capability
the framework covers the questions
customers have asked us
in the areas of the technology to
develop platforms and solutions
the people who will implement and manage
that technology
the data that fuels that technology and
the processes that govern the whole of
it
success requires an integrated lens
between these areas
the interplay between these four areas
gives rise to six
themes learn lead
access secure scale and automate
based on our experience with customers
these are the six
themes you need to address to be
successful
to briefly introduce each theme
learn is the interplay between people
and technology
it entails hiring talent upskilling your
staff through learning programs
and working with experienced partners
lead is the interplay between people and
process
it refers to leaders sponsoring ai
initiatives and how teams are structured
and collaborate with each other
access is the interplay between people
and data
it's about data management and making
data assets and machine learning
artifacts
discoverable shareable and reusable
secure is the interplay between data and
process
it addresses how you classify and
protect data
build fair systems and implement
responsible ai
practices scale is the interplay between
data and technology
it covers how you use cloud native
services to scale with big data sets and
a large number of jobs without
operational overhead and lastly
automate is the interplay between
technology and process
it encompasses deploying executing and
operating technology for machine
learning pipelines in production
efficiently frequently and reliably
your readiness is determined by your
current business practices
in each of the six themes across three
phases
tactical strategic and transformational
in the tactical phase the focus is on
easy adoption
minimal disruption and quick wins
different teams experiment with
simple analytics use cases and benefit
from improved actionable insights from
data
for example using basic descriptive
analytics to create a customer
segmentation model complex problems are
outsourced to partners
in the strategic phase ai is used to
deliver sustainable business value for
your organization
you typically form a centralized team
ensuring coordination
consistent standards and governance a
broader vision steers ai adoption
and your organization has several
machine learning systems deployed and
maintained in production
like propensity modeling demand
forecasting
and recommendations leveraging data sets
from an enterprise data warehouse
in the transformational phase ai plays a
key
role in the organization stimulating
innovation and supporting agility
to create state-of-the-art algorithms
for example
using the language model bert to extract
information and answer questions from
covet research papers
you cultivate a culture where
experimentation and learning is
continuous and encouraged
machine learning expertise has diffused
across the lines of business
and there is a mechanism in place for
scaling and promoting
machine learning capabilities across the
organization
all teams are empowered through a
platform that enables access to useful
data sets
prepared features reusable components
and trained models
when you overlay the six themes learn
lead access secure scale and automate
and the three phases tactical strategic
and transformational you get the ai
maturity skill
you can use the ai maturity skill to
assess where you are
and define where you want to go the goal
isn't necessarily to become
transformational in every aspect but to
get value
every step of the way now i'll hand over
to khalid
who will dive deeper into the maturity
scale for each theme
thank you donna so the first thing to
discuss
is learn as donna mentioned it concerns
aspects like
upskilling hiring and collaboration with
partners
in the tactical phase we've seen that
learning about data science
and machine learning is usually isolated
and self-motivated
your organization tends to turn to
third-party consultants when facing
compelling machine learning use cases
rather than hiring to fill the gaps in
the skill set
as your organization start to build the
greater air capability in-house
you hire the required skills for data
science and machine learning
typically organizations start to hire
machine learning engineers
in addition to data scientists to be
able to productionize their machine
learning models
you also develop clear learning paths
with certification to upscale your staff
for example using our google cloud
training and certification programs
we've recently launched the professional
machine learning engineer certification
to assist your team's ability to design
and build machine learning system in
google cloud
from a partnership perspective your
organization chooses a strategic partner
to provide specialized knowledge in
specific ai use cases
for example automating document
processing or building conversational
apps
moving to the transformational phase
we've seen customers encouraging
peer-to-peer and community learning
creating internal knowledge bases and
wikis
and allowing staff rotations across
business functions to ensure title
collaboration and exchange of experience
your organization now aims at hiring ai
and machine learning talent with
industry expertise
to lead research and innovation efforts
now let's move to the lead theme which
concerns with
business leadership support and team
structure and collaboration
in the early phase of the maturity air
adoption is driven by individual
contributors
with little or no executive sponsorship
thus
the machine learning initiatives might
not have a clear alignment with your
organization's strategic goals the key
step is to start with your organization
business strategy and priority
to identify the right machine learning
use cases and pursue executive
sponsorship
as your senior executives realizes the
importance of ai for creating
competitive advantage
they support and fund ai projects to
deliver
value for various business functions now
you can establish a centralized
cross-functional advanced analytics
scene
to standardize the practices and guides
and guidelines
and to achieve strategic ai agenda this
advanced analytics team works on
delivering prioritized machine learning
projects
and proactively clarifying how ai can
effectively
address different use cases
in the transformational phase each
functional team has its own data
scientists
with the right domain specific expertise
having a centralized machine learning
engineering team and embedded data
scientists in the in the business
functions
ensures both strong technical standards
and effective business alliance
as ai shows to be impactful to your
business the c-level executives
continuously demonstrate
active sponsor for innovative ai
products
such research and innovation projects
aim at solving cutting-edge business
problems
and establishing the organization name
as a market leader
the third theme in our framework is
access which concerns
effective data management to enable
shareability discoverability and
reusability
in the early stages each team usually
manages its own data island and machine
learning assets
with no sharing among other teams
as a tactical step to update your
strategy you can look into building a
data lake
containing the the role structured and
unstructured data feeds
from across your disparate systems this
can form the foundation for collecting
curating and shading data across your
organization
and creating managed information objects
as your organization recognizes that as
a vital enterprise asset that fuels ai
you invest in building an enterprise
data warehouse which provides an
integrated information store and a
unified data model for
different business functions the data
warehouse empowers
data analysts data scientists and data
engineers to perform their
data wrangling exploration and analytics
activities
for example we work with a media
customer that successfully
uses bigquery as their enterprise-wide
data warehouse
this enabled their various teams to
perform analytical queries and
information retrieval from a centralized
location
besides you start to put together a
centralized repository for machine
learning assets
like notebooks and code templates and
develop tools for annotating and
categorizing
datasets and other assets to enable
discoverability and reusability
data quality management at this stage is
a business priority
to ensure the right foundation for
analytics and ai
in the transformational phase your
organization is actively
working to develop the technology and
processes to allow data scientists to
create
share discover and reuse data and
machine learning assets
across different teams and functions
moreover
to standardizing the definition storage
and access of machine learning data sets
you invest in implementing a feature
store a feature store can be a federated
repository for registering new features
and discovering existing ones to be used
by dead scientists
now we move to the secure theme the
security and concerns with protecting
your data
securing your machine learning services
and ensuring
responsible ai
as a tactical step to enable air
adoption with confidence
your organization defines the identity
and access management policies
and security controls to protect your
data and ai services
in addition you ensure data privacy
through constant sensitive data
classification
and obfuscation
in the strategic phase your
organizations start to implement a
comprehensive
data governance program covering data
access auditing
lineage tracking data privacy and
compliance
and establishing responsible ai
practices
responsible ai practices ensure building
fair and explainable ai solutions
to maintain the desired level of trust
in ai
throughout your business functions for
more information
we recommend watching the session on
responsible ai from theory to practice
by tracy3
in the transformational phase your data
governance is streamlined
using automated workflows to rapidly
validate new use cases against the
domain regulations
and your ai principles in addition you
invest in ai safety and robustness
to improve the reliability and
generalizability of your machine
learning models
the scale theme covers using cloud
native services and accelerators to
scale your machine learning workloads
in the tactical phase your organization
aim at controlling the cost of
experimenting with machine learning
thus you usually dedicate cloud
resources with limited compute power
for a few data scientists who work with
small offline datasets
at the strategic phase data interest and
transformation are performed using
managed processing services
like data flow and data proc to execute
large-scale batch and streaming etl jobs
similarly machine learning training and
batch scoring jobs are performed using
cloud managed services
this enables running powerful machine
learning algorithms
on large datasets at scale with no
infrastructure overhead
for example we work with a digital
native customer who used to run their
machine learning workflows on dedicated
vms however
by moving to the ai platform which
provides managed services to train and
deploy machinery models
the customer now is able to scale their
training and scoring jobs to more
markets
as well as to reduce the cost of running
these jobs
as you move to the transformational
phase you invest in establishing a
unified
and integrated machine learning platform
which helps to
streamline the transition from
experimentation to production
and to serve all data scientists and
machine learning engineers in different
teams
this integrated platform provides access
to standardized tools
frameworks templates services
accelerators
and processes for the entire
organization
finally we cover the automate theme
which concerns with
deploying executing and operating
machine learning workloads in production
in the tactical phase the process to
build ai systems is usually manual in
every step
from data analysis and preparation to
model training and deployment
such a manual process prevents the
organization from scaling the number of
models they use
and the frequency of updating these
models
as your organization moves to the
strategic phase you automate data
processing and analytics pipelines to be
executed on recurrent schedules
or to tackle critical events and
triggers
at this stage you deploy end-to-end
continuous training pipelines
to regularly update your machine
learning models with new data
this enables your model to rapidly adapt
to the changes in the dynamics of your
business
for example we're currently working with
a telecom company to automate treatment
retraining their propensity models using
tfx and keyflow pipelines
allowing the models to be updated weekly
instead of updating them manually
each six or eight weeks
in the transformational phase your goal
is to develop a machine learning
engineering culture and practice that
unifies both machine learning system
development
and machine learning system operations
we call that mlaps
mloff strongly advocates automation and
monitoring at all steps of machine
learning system construction
with this approach you are looking
towards a shorter deployment cycles
increased deployment velocity and faster
time to market
this however requires robust quality
control throughout the machine learning
training and deployment phases
as well as continuous training and
monitor continuous monitoring of your
model's performance in production
back to donate to conclude thank you
khalid
to summarize the three key points of our
framework
are one anyone can use this framework
no matter where you're starting you can
use this framework to define your ai
strategy
and drive successful adoption two
success requires an integrated lens in
order to build an effective ai
capability
you need to address six themes learn
lead access secure scale and automate
and three there's value every step of
the way it's not about becoming
transformational in every aspect
it's about gaining value in each phase
so what can you do next you can create a
group of leaders who will be responsible
for your ai strategy
and from there each of you should use
this framework to identify
where you are in your ai journey then
collectively set your goal where do you
envision your organization going
based on the gaps establish a plan for
evolving your ai capability
we are here to help you every step of
the way check out our resources and read
our white paper
for more information thank you for
watching
this session